好吧 我今天先講一下那個
我覺得大島宏觀的形勢其實並沒有什麼特別大的變化
就是我們的觀點也沒有特別大變化
上週的話有很多的政治的影響
就是其實在上兩週的時候我們一直談到
就是說政治可能給市場帶來波動性
我談一下政治可能會對後面整體市場風險偏好的一些影響
還有上週發生了什麼事情
然後我覺得這週主要講一下
因為上週也有問到
就是現在也是市場比較關心的一個焦點
就是日遠的利率和到了燕的走勢
然後可能有不少投資人比較擔心的是
到了燕會不會造成一波n wine
然後導致到了燕的carry trade n wine
然後是不是會影響市場
所以我說一下主要說一下那個year rate
就日遠的利率和日遠的匯率
可能會對市場的衝擊
後續的會有什麼衝擊
然後上週上週其實波動還是很大的
三迷這一邊
昨天晚上其實covips拿了那個
拿了那個V典錢
我覺得這個事情也分析一下
就是特別是關於erny c的
就是接下來的幾個大的運營廠要包容你
然後加上英偉達的那些營利情況
但英偉達營利
然後這些雲的營利情況
和雲的其實大家關注的比較cat tax的情況
然後我說一下我的看法就是erny的看法
然後和erny的看法
然後日遠的匯率利率的看法
和一些政治上的波動
首先我覺得政治上的波動
帶來的政治上的一些事件帶來的是波動性
它其實帶來的不一定是方向性
就是我們看到兩個主見其實並沒有變化
就是說第一個是
我們從前年其實就看到這幾年會有一個
我們叫財政政策的不負責性
就是那個全世界其實財政政策都不是很負責
那麼其實美元利率也是一樣的
包括預言利率
那個erny的也在Steven
這個我美元利率放的是上前五天
所以美元利率後來最近crashdown了一些
但是你如果往前面看一個月
幾個月的話
其實美元利率也是在我們上週說可以去買swaping的時候
就是達到了一個高點
就是在那個上週是高點
其實如果上週進swaping的話
那現在就非常爽
所以我是覺得就是說利率市場
其實改變了過去18多月的利率市場
跟在以前是很不一樣的
就是說以前利率你可以把它認為是一個riskage
就是我們風險資產上來講
那個債和股是走反過來走的
如果風險偏好不好的時候
那麼就會債就會漲一漲
過去18個月利率市場很大程度上
變成了一個對沖財政不確定性
或者財政不負責性的郵工具
就是它開始吹的很多risk premium
there's a 10 premium risk
10 premium risk什麼意思呢
就兩說我覺得美國財政不負責
然後美國大量發債
然後我就把它的債給跑一跑
那國債是這樣子
其實比較明顯的就是在日元上的一個走勢
日元rate過去一個月很大程度上在steep
那個steep意思就是長端的利率一直在變高
然後其實中間有兩部分利量
就是我們會看得到
就是在那個銀行端大量的日本的本地銀行
包括本地銀行在減少自己的duration
就是它不太想吃有特別長端的利率
因為確實不知道那個日本的財政不負責性
或者變什麼樣子
高市呢
其實高市做了一個在政治上很博弈的事情
就它其實剛剛上台的時候
它自己支持率非常高
它最高的時候可能到了70以上吧
然後但是它在眾議院裡面
它那個LDP就是自民黨的這個支持
就席位它沒有過半
所以它現在就採取把那個議員給中心大選了
趁自己支持率比較高的時候
它要控制議會
然後控制議會其實主要的事情
它是要通過它所謂的新的財政政策
它新的財政政策上週公布的時候
這也是讓那個日元利率其實上週
日元在匯率在上週一直在貶值也很重要的原因
就是它的匯率
其實你走勢是匯率在貶值
同時的話利率在升高
它的利率在走Steepen的路徑
就是它公布的這個
它的這個政策是說要減
比方說消費稅消費稅
就對於食品類的消費稅吧
它要減5萬億
總的財政赤字122萬億
就是日本
那麼這就是財政赤字日本其實搞了很長時間
但是最近其實一個其實帶著有一點通脹的影響
就日本其實帶有通脹的
那麼在貨幣政策端其實那個BOJ
本來是想加息的嘛
然後可能就是到了6 7月份還是會加一次息
然後再有通脹壓力的時候
大家覺得財政政策
貨幣政策其實它的餘地不是特別大
然後為了高市其實是為了經濟增長
它繼續繼續搞財政政策
所以大家覺得OK
那你沒有辦法拼命引錢了
然後那個利率的起勁
我就把利率給你包含
所以這個利率債其實十年期
其實這是十年期
其實更長期的整個Curve都在變Stefan
就是長端的債一直在漲
但是而且銀行在Row Over就是把它變成更短
包括Hedge Fund在N1很多長端的這個Position
就是導致這個其實日元匯率在貶值
然後利率在漲
那麼同時的話
其實這跟美國的情況我覺得比較相似
每一次你去定價財政不負責性
其實市場沒有意識到的問題是財政不負責性
它伴隨著可能是貨幣的同時不負責性
所以你在上週五的時候
那個我們看到BOG出來的聲明
5.1大本來大家預期的聲明
它是會非常強硬的
就是我相對來說會更加好歸是一點
但是它實際的聲明出來講到了一個問題
就是說如果說它對於日元貶值
可能對通脹帶來有意的影響是刻意說了這麼一句話
所以大家覺得日元可能會繼續貶值
然後他們BOG沒有辦法真正採取非常強硬的措施
特別是在政府財政政策可能會更加寬鬆
然後應對通脹的時候
BOG的屁股其實永遠是坐在防止通縮那邊
那這個不光是BOG
我之前講過這個問題
就是大家很擔心日本加息
然後導致Carry trailer 1
其實日本央行的屁股永遠真正的是坐在防止通縮這一邊
防止經濟衰退
同樣的包括美聯儲
包括ECB
包括PBOC
就是包括通過央行
都是這樣
就是它是面子上維持通脹的控制
實際上是最最擔心的經濟衰退和通縮
特別是在整個財政不負責
就是我們看到整個財政不負責
是cross-board
是各個國家都會這個樣子
那麼這個過程後面的結果就是很有可能流動性過於快
就我們大家會講到
就是我們為什麼我為什麼是一直覺得今年是個大牛市
就是在通脹出來之前
我們看到快的expansion
快的expansion就是信貸的擴張
信貸擴張背後就是財政上的支出
然後加上derigolation
我們看到derigolation就是那個特別包括美國
金融的去鋼管
金融的加鋼管去監管
然後我待會還會講
就是美元的一些read carry trade
導致整個市場流行就是很好
那麼日遠的匯率
在上週五的時候被打擊了一下
可能這一波門跌下來
其實是在日本那個央行選舉之前
不是央行選舉
在日本議會選舉之前
2月9號吧
好像是
反正我記得是2月9號
2月9號選舉之前
那個BOJ通過美國美聯儲
就是美聯儲紐約聯儲去市場上做了一個雙邊選票
那麼大家覺得呢
BOJ可能會干涉匯率
就它沒有辦法放任匯率不停的門跌
但是其實BOJ的屁股是坐在
它是希望匯率比較穩定的在那裡跌
然後希望它那個利率不會受到網上上當太大的影響
所以它是其實屁股是坐在戈海那裡的
但是在短期裡面
它可能需要干涉一下市場
那麼央行出來可能要干涉
它當然它read直接crash了
crash到那個匯率
就是要crash到155
155 154
那我說一下它對那個整個carry tree的影響
就是大家討論很多carry tree
因為知道carry tree的是說
我們把日元借出去
然後去投了美元
然後如果日元上升的carry tree
其實就要平倉嘛
然後日元如果走強的話
carry tree也要平倉
那麼carry tree的本質上這麼多年
像一個顏色壺一樣
就是日本一直在印很多的錢給全世界
特別是美國或資本市場提供很大的流動性
然後市場上有兩部分觀點
一部分就覺得這個影響沒有那麼大
然後第二部分就以那個microbarry這些人為主
他們覺得carry tree很壞
會給市場招了很大的憧憬
它本身是一個極大的公投
它還拿這個算力中心它的晶片折價
然後來做空
包括英偉達和Oracle這些公司的股票
就是它是一個大空頭
當然carry tree也是中間它的一個邏輯
然後我說一下我個人的看法
我覺得日元利率上升和日元匯率
對carry tree影響沒有那麼大
為什麼呢
就首先我們對比一下2024年的情況
2024年carry tree的大規模N1的時候
它是一個突發的
就是它並不是利率在往部的上升
它確實是在往部上升
對carry tree會往外
但是極具的carry tree的馬貨
對市場造成很大影響
其實並不是rate itself
不是利率本身
而是利率volatility
那我們上週其實講過利率implival
最近如果肯定上來了
但是利率implival一直在下降
這是美元的
然後其實日元的implival也並沒有那麼高
我這裡沒有貼出來
但是並不是2024年這種直接vol spike up
就是現在跟過去不同了
就我開篇就講的
就是說現在利率是作為一個temporary risk
temporary risk的一個押注
而不是作為risk catch property的
所以不是作為對沖
對沖市場風險拼耗的這個資產
如果不是完全作為對沖市場風險拼耗資產的
這個利率的波動和對市場影響可能會更大
那麼在現在日元利率會繼續往上走
因為本質上日本自民黨的政策財政上不太負責
但是它並不是一個幾句快速
就是那個波動非常大的上升
第二個其實本質上在央行干涉之前
它辦事的是日元走落
所以你當你做carry tree的時候
其實日元走落對你是好的
因為你記得是日元嗎
它雖然去干涉了
但是大家都看到了
其實財政和貨幣政策
就貨幣政策本質上它也不是那麼負責
所以你很難守住日元的匯率
它這個匯率是往走落的方向去走的
利率是債也是往貶
這是跌的方向走的
就是利率往上面走的
所以這兩個趨勢其實同時在發生
你不要看那個短期的單涉
但是同時在發生的時候
carry tree並沒有趨勢性的大規模的屏藏
而且carry tree的規模
沒有像Mac ver.他們說這麼大
二次年其實屏了
二次年那一次其實確實倉貨非常激壯
但是現在的carry tree沒有那麼大的規模
所以我覺得就是總結上來說
會有moderate的屏藏發生
但是利率Vol的影響比利率本身更大
然後carry tree我沒有看到有大規模屏藏
導致acquity補票
這個很大衝擊的
現在沒有看到這很大衝擊的趨勢
我覺得相對來說還可以
然後第二個就是日本本身國內的一個
我們看到flow的一個情況
就是雖然月初的時候
就是在這裡吧
月初的時候
不是月初就星期初的時候
上星期初的時候
確實是有很多H1P
然後有銀行card duration
Banker duration
這個都是很明確的
但是在星期四星期五的時候
有大量的real money buy
就是real money重新stepping
去buy duration去買長期的
就覺得長期可能也就這樣了
所以包括那個upcoming
就是因為很多新聞炒作
炒新聞包括炒news
就是叫做財政政策
你們覺得它財政政策
會有很大的問題
包括當時炒到
那個美國財政政策有問題
美元有問題
美國國債有問題
其實都是沒有問題的
因為真正要在宏觀上
讓這個國家的財政出問題
這伴隨著它貨幣政策
控制在自己手上財政出問題
最後一定是要有通脹
它貨幣徹底手腳被綁住
這種情況下才會有出問題
現在日本雖然有通脹
它其實也沒有那麼嚴重
就是美國肯定是現在沒有通脹
所以最後你如果說
是真的是有通脹的威脅財政
貨幣政策上是沒有辦法採取行動的
那你財政政策就是要讓步的
所以在日本的情況下
很有可能財政政策
是會有一定的讓步
那麼在那個後面幾次
那個高市的這個表態的時候
其實已經對於財政沒有那麼
就是沒有口氣那麼強硬
包括它說到這個
政府可能會採取bound back
就是我會去買債
然後把長短利率給壓低
然後這個其實就是直接政府印錢
也沒有什麼區別 對吧
然後第二個就是它會講到
它的這個財政赤字計劃
可能有一段時間
就是會把那個duration時間放長
那我債欠的時間更長
那麼執行的時間可能會放長
這些其實在日本都已經
就是這些新聞回來以後
利潤利率是往下了一些
所以我是覺得就是利潤利率
整體財政不負責
它是會往上
但是它的財政政策
如果是自己把自己玩脫了
玩爆料就概率不是特別大
它有各種方法去控制它
包括bound back
然後包括把那個市場實在動了太多了
比方說當時美國國債動了實在太多的時候
其實政府稍微把那個態度降降溫
它都會回來
包括那個央行
美國的美聯儲和日本的BOJ
它都會採取一些措施
所以你在跟央行和國家去做對手盤的時候
你一定要壓住它爆倉
那除非是你一定要壓住國家爆倉的話
你除非是通脹失控
所以在中國也是同樣的情況
就是中國現在M0可能翻了一倍吧
就是基礎貨幣其實翻了一倍
那個資本市場基本上過去一年半
一年半就是印錢給你出來
所以它國家的意志要在那裡大搞大水漫灌
其實它如果出問題的話
像洽諾貝利亞它是爆在一個點上
它不是那麼一個週期
就是你預判那個點是非常非常難
然後在這個路上一直要跟它做對的話
你在路上其實一直在negative carry
就一直在流血
並不是一個非常愉快的市場經驗
那麼本質上我是覺得至少在
這是日本的情況
日本我覺得carry tree不會導致整個
global equity風險資產的一個巨大的問題
然後同時的話
我剛剛講到特別講到美國
那美國流動性為什麼特別好呢
就是這個全球財政政策是一個
美國金融區觀感
金融加槓感去監管是一個
還有第三個就是在美國的利率上
有一個稱Premium Carrier Tree
那就是我去借短期的站
然後再去養長期的站
這個交易其實在美國
現在我覺得沒有非常可怕
沒有 就是方慶
方慶被挨
就剛開始
就沒有大量的頭存積累
但是會繼續搞下去
所以那個十年期利率
你要它跑到很高
我覺得很難很難的
這就是為什麼我在那個
雖然美國財政也不是什麼特別負責
就是特朗普也不是非常特別負責
他接下去還要搞這些fulability
因為這個中級選舉中間
voter現在更加投票的人
更加擔心的是fulability
就是我的食品
我的那個utility
我的電價
然後我的housing
這些東西
而不是關稅移民這些議題
所以fulability會變成Trump
我其實上座也講過
fulability會變成Trump
只剩的中間一個很重要的一個焦點
雖然他的議會上面可能過不去
但是他會對每個公司行業
來把他去施壓
那麼
十年期利率的問題是
美國稱Premium Carried Trade
就是說雖然我沒有
我會要發很多展
但是問題是三件事情
我覺得不太會有很大的變化
第一個是不會有很大的通脹
就在美國的話通脹
十年期利率跑到頂了
我覺得差不多跑到頂
然後很難突破4.25
然後或者突破到4.5
如果你碰到上面
那我絕對是一個機會直接做多活債
我一直理你去買債
然後買長期債
然後長期利率往下跑
那第一個為什麼呢
就是說我們沒有看到很強的通脹
通脹的預期都非常長
這個是一個
第二個呢
美聯儲的政策
不管現在美聯儲主席誰選出來
我可以簡單說一下
這四個人的差別等一下
但是美國美聯儲基本上
我覺得也是會比較寬鬆的政策
就是不管是哪個人選上來
現在相對來說
因為我上次講過
就是聯儲我們認為是一個火車
已經離戰了
所以他們可能會變得
Rick可能跟市場Orentia的一點
就是更加比方說
市場不好的時候
更加根據市場變化來調整利率
那麼他會調得比較快
跌的時候調得比較快
然後如果市場展現風險平衡過多的時候
他可能會有點像Grinspan
就是市場風險平衡太大的時候
他有可能會往上調也會比較快
那如果是那個就是嘛
其他兩個其他幾個人呢
可能會對經濟數據更加敏感一點
但是Kalmwash這個人
其實相對來說是一個risk of的
因為他以前一直說
聯儲要降低Balance的之類的
那麼但是即使如此的話
他其實創不選他的話
我覺得他也會多一次降息
所以現在利率市場上
第一個inflation沒有
第二個就是美聯儲的政策
相對來說比較穩定
沒有這麼大的分歧
第三個呢 labor market很差
就是你會看到
包括所有的大科技公司
接下去幾個月都會裁員
他裁員包括銀行股票漲了很多
銀行其實去年也裁員了百分之
我們上週講過
然後那個科技公司也會裁員
因為AR本身是為一種生產力
在替代他們
那個整體美國就業市場
其實並不是特別好
那麼這種情況下
我們會認為利率的volatility
會繼續下降
這個下降的趨勢
就是不會特別升高
這個下降趨勢
其實已經維持了半年多了
那麼在 vol 比較低的時候
利率 vol 比較低的時候
一個很簡單的交易
就是我們可以去界短暫後買長暫
那麼界短暫買長暫
或者是界短期的錢買 mortgage
這兩個交易都是叫
那個 rate carriage rate
或者 10 premium carriage rate
10 premium carriage rate
會延續一段時間
直到什麼時候呢
直到第二次 inflation 再出來
通脹再出來
那這個可能我們要等到
不知道了等到明年
就今年肯定是
我覺得很難很難利率再出現
再出來
所以今年雖然有大量的發展
那發展也沒有去年多
然後就我們叫DBO
也沒有去年多
但是在這個情況下
大家會不停的買很多的國債
特別是銀行
現在又被區檢管了
所以會買很多
就是需求會很大
carriage rate 是槓桿的
所以十年期的利率
會面臨一個比較大的
就是往上的這個瓶頸的
補上不太去
這個也是帶給市場流動型
所以我覺得市場
在一個什麼樣的環境下
市場在一個趨勢性的往上
就是我風險自償
在一個趨勢性往上
那這後面feel
就是燃料是
燃料是過多的流動性
流動性比較多
第二個是供資能而已
那我簡單說一下供資能而已
因為很多做空
雲啊做空
英偉達這些公司的動力
都是說我現在芯片
表述英偉大的GPU芯片
芯片出來以後
芯片要折價的
它的燃頭會下降的
這個就相當於我買個房子
我的房租一直在降
因為有新的芯片出來
但是這個趨勢
在12月份的10月份
完全被逆轉了
它的這個是H100的
H100是老片
老卡租金上升很多
然後為什麼用老卡租金
因為新卡根本租不到
就是新卡沒有市場的
就是你現在想去租B100芯片
你就不可能拿得到
所以英偉達不但是說老卡
不但是說新卡完全賣完
現在H200和B100完全無貨
就是新的卡根本就拿不到
是其實
我覺得你們可以去看一下
傑平某根最近一個報告
就講到這個問題
就當講到語音啊
CAPEX
其實我們會看到
語音的公司比方說29號
就後天
後天那個Microsoft會出Earning
Microsoft Earning
我覺得
Aerial可能會加速
就是它的語音可能會加速
到39%到40%的增速
然後CAPEX都會增加
大概1250億左右
這我覺得大概是
我們的情報是會beat
就是超過市場1%到2%
也就是它在各個公司
在語音上的投入會繼續加速
然後在語音上收錄也會增加
那很簡單
我租金都在上升
那我相當於我收房租的
我肯定在租金再增加
背後是AI上算力的需求
就是供需到保准
它用了一個字叫insolvable
是無法被解決的
這個中間反饋的可能是
我們看到的存儲漲到
現在小米和榮耀手機
已經沒法出貨了
連車都沒法出貨
因為人家對於你消費電子
根本就不幫你當客戶了
就給你斷控
因為我先去滿足算力中心
然後我們會看到GPU的芯片
其實已經缺貨缺到
根本就買不到
然後所有的協議
比方說我要去租這個芯片
協議都是長期的
現在全部是長期
因為我要鎖定
就是使用者都要鎖定
然後創業公司
或者是那個新的要去培養
算力的公司
只能回頭去租H100
然後租H100還未必拿到到貨
拿到到就不錯
唯一一種拿到貨的就是H100
所以這個市場背後就絕本的
我剛講的
宏觀市場上的兩個大推理
一個是快樂 Expansion
快樂 Expansion可能會帶來
就是信貸的這個擴張
會帶來CAPEX
就投資更多的投資
更多的金雲算力中心之類的
然後還有就是
因為供訊矛盾無法被解決
所以公司盈利非常好
就我們會看到公司盈利很強
那個從語音開始
語音我覺得就因為
最近你被壓了很長時間了
然後GPU包括盈利大
這些盈利都很好
那個全部beat
英特爾是另外一個時候
英特爾我私下推測上講過很多次
英特爾是他們那個做CPU的
其實不太敢
當時在落後現場上去做投入
然後但是落後現場的需求太大
然後他們其實存貨已經全部用完了
然後就是我要市場上太多了
存貨用完了
我生產跟不上
所以股票給你跌了一下
但是你後面看AMD
我覺得AMD也一樣
就是大家現在訂在CPU缺貨
然後AMD要去搶一臺份
我覺得不存在AMD也缺貨
就這個CPU全部全貨
這個背後就是會帶來那個盈利
所以整個市場的大趨勢
我覺得沒有變化
那麼財政帶來的什麼呢
就是新聞帶來的什麼
就是包括川普在格林蘭的問題上
在達伯斯已經變成一個轉碼了
就是公開的在美國和歐洲
Chance Atlantic關係裡面
告訴大家
我們開始搞孤立主義
這是一個達伯斯
重生一個很重要的一個take
就是美國從全球化的美國
轉為蒙俄主義的美國
就是轉為美洲的美國
那麼再加上有那個接下去
有阿依帕去ruled out
那個川普特朗普的事情
就是那個就是最高法院
去現在沒判決還沒下來
最後會不會怎麼判
對於那個特朗普加關稅
然後還有那個
你們最近可能看到了
Milissola的那個槍擊
所以這些事情都是在
政治上的影響都是在短期裡面
或者是一段時間裡面
市場增加不確定性
然後增加波動率
但是市場最後看的還是盈利
經濟增長
就公司賺多少錢
所以這個又是
中國公司賺多少錢
市場有沒有錢
市場流動性怎麼樣
就是基礎是不差的
但是中間波動很大
所以我覺得就是說
今年的還是這麼一個行情
就是一個正當上行的趨勢
然後正當過程中
你可能會非常痛苦
但是正當到一個什麼程度
到底是這個正當會往下跌多少
會不會跌
都是不太確定
因為你回頭看黑命貴的時候
美國股市也沒怎麼跌
當然當時也沒有像現在這樣走到
一個特別高的好點
但是黑命貴確實股市是反漲的
因為當時流動性好
公司盈利好
現在情況也是一樣的
你這個人被打死了
就在Milipolis被打死了
然後他是被埃斯被那個移民局
等於是被拍下來
就是被直接在地上被槍擊打死
這個事情
視頻你們可以去看一下
但是最後就說一下
這個東西是世界的影響
這個世界的影響很有可能
民主黨會All in
去跟特朗普作鬥爭
那個現在黨派之爭
其實意識形態的鬥爭
在美國左右意識形態的鬥爭
已經蔓延到全世界了
在那個Dubbos其實
背後就是我們右派的思潮
就是創他們右派的思潮
對於歐洲現在左傾的傾向
其實非常不滿
他們他把自己的盟友
其實用第三人稱
NATO他的那個北約
他北約盟友
他用第三人稱他們
是這麼去稱呼的
那一樣
現在民主黨大概率在國內
因為會因為已經死了
第二個人
第一個是開車被打死
第二個在路邊被打死
他很有可能會因為這個事情
把政府給關門
因為1月31號還有一個
其實上一次
短期的政府官們的這個協議
到1月31號到期
所以民主黨會很有可能說
我要把那個移民局的訪問給看掉
Ice的訪問給看掉
為了這個事情
跟那個共和黨政府把政府關一下
我覺得這個可能性非常大
就是他們現在
一方面製造大家商街
尤其是搞瘟瘓
就是Protest
就是抗議
然後同時的話
因為他們很有可能就把政府
放進給你關掉
然後讓你Ice不能上街
所以這個黨派之爭
會在短期裡面
給市場造了很大的動蕩
就這個動蕩背後
你怎麼樣在風險資產上面去Hatch
是不是空艙
我覺得非常不合適
因為你空艙的話
你看本質上的這個
酸力革命和酸力的需求
死活放在那裏
那我還是覺得
你如果說是市場
你要做對沖的話
當然我們是上周講到
在這個位置對沖
那是非常爽的
這個是十年期
在一個特別高的高點上周講
但是我覺得
在這個路徑中間
雖然現在十年期
歷歷下來了很多
但是如果真的發生
政府關門這種事件
還有十幾二十個
Base point的空間
政府一旦關門
跟去年年底的時候
這個關門一樣
就是發債會停掉
供應會停掉
所以十年歷歷
就是會很快的下去
所以並不是說
我們覺得財政不負責
就應該去壓住這個歷歷
往上崩盤
我覺得在現在
經濟情況下不太一樣
現在所有的歐洲
日本美國
包括中國
都是同樣的路徑
就是我在財政上不負責
我在貨幣上假裝負責
這個是大家的
認清這個形式的話
其實做法是相反
就是你每一次在歷歷
往上跑到頂點的時候
你應該反過來做
你覺得它會掉來
這個我覺得是一個
但是它也是個range bond
因為本質上
它也不是特別負責的
所以如果是真的到了4.0
長期歷歷到4.0
你又可以反向
這個大概是
我們也看到
總結一下
我覺得就是整個市場
是還偏樂觀的
中間的政治上會造成各種
各種影響
沒有看到日元利率
或者Dollar Yan rate
Yan rate或Dollar Yan FX rate
對市場會有很大的carriage rate的影響
但是確實短期
會有很多不確定性
這個是一個月兩個月
或者幾個月兩個季度
但是公司引力
我們看到是
後面的奧尼口
我們對奧尼的看法
是偏樂觀
就特別是對於雲GPU的缺貨
CPU不是
CPU缺貨沒有辦法馬上變成雲
就是CPU缺貨要幾個季度才變成雲
所以它是一個慢鈕
它不應該是個快鈕
然後GPU的缺貨是非常確定
然後整體雲的
雲算你的需求也是非常強
好吧
大致我我這樣講一下
看看你們有什麼問題
我們可以Q&A的顯示
我按錯了